we have once again multiple examples of
these strange brain glitches that some
are calling colloquially mini-strokes
happening to Donald Trump from last
night's State of the Union speech I
don't know what this is I am NOT a
medical professional I have gotten
emails from neurologists who say David D
seemed possibly like mini-strokes
sometimes dementia can cause this
sometimes it can be medication it can be
drug abuse
some say it's parkinsonian I don't know
what it is but something is not right
I'm going to play for you two examples
from last night it's very visual so if
you're listening to the podcast or on
the radio find the video on our youtube
channel what happens is that Donald
Trump will simultaneously mess up a word
sort of like the record skips and
sometimes he'll say a nonsense word and
at the exact same time his shoulders
spasm and he seems to sort of turn to
cover it he looks confused for a moment
and then he goes back to reading the
teleprompter in this first clip Donald
Trump is trying to read the word
sanctuary from his teleprompter we
noticed this one live on the state of
the union stream last night and instead
Donald Trump says sanctuary and right
when he says it his body spasms the
shoulder twitch happens and Trump turns
let's take a look at this first clip
California passed an outrageous load
declaring their whole state to be a
stink cheeri for criminal illegal the
state of California passed an outrageous
law declaring their whole state to be a
stinking or for criminal illegal the
state of California passed an outrageous
load declare again it's like the record
skips from mrs. or miss states all or
part of a word his shoulders spasm and
then he goes right back to reading after
a brief moment of confusion here's
another example from last night this one
Trump is talking he's either talking
about Qasem Soleimani or Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi and Trump was trying to say
he directed the December and he glitches
he says that he says that he directed
December and simultaneously the
shoulders flinch from spasms and then
Trump turns to sort of try to cover it
almost like he knows that it's happening
honey orchestrated the deaths of
countless men women and children he
directed the December dassault and went
on to assault the US forces in Iraq
we're not making fun of medical
conditions we're noticing that this is
happening there's not an explanation
that has been given there's no serious
medical evaluation that's been done of
Donald Trump that we can trust the one
we have says he's 6-3 and weighs 239
pounds if you believe that I've got a
bridge to sell you
and this does not seem normal now a
couple of other reminders of recent
examples this this was one on the word
criminals at a recent rally where the
same type of glitch happened Democrats
decided to shield and shelter look look
wait you have criminals all right
watching the president here in Wildwood
New Jersey I just want to get a quick
comment before we toss it over to chuck
or Molly Hemingway and then remember
another recent instance of this wall
Donald Trump was speaking to the
right-wing group Turning Point USA we
want to know what's going on quite
simply it is happening too much for it
to be nothing the confusion on Trump's
face the spasm and the recognition that
something seems to have happened that
Trump seems to experience suggests to me
this is not nothing what it is I don't
know I hope at some point we learn and
we figure it out let me know what you
think I want to encourage everybody in
my audience to go subscribe to a YouTube
channel we're partnering with it's
called up flip they release new videos
every week in every video you meet a
different entrepreneur and get an
in-depth look at how their business
works and how they became successful
it's great if you like shows like shark
tank if you own your own business or
you're thinking of starting one the up
flip
YouTube channel really does offer a
wealth of knowledge and inspiration as
an entrepreneur myself and a business
owner I've really been enjoying hearing
all of the different stories of the
people that they interview but it's
really fascinating content even if you
don't own your own business to go check
out the up flip YouTube channel they're
friends of the David Pakman show I'd
love it if you would support them by
subscribing to their channel you can
find the up flip YouTube channel by
going to david pakman.com slash up flip
if you're watching this on youtube i've
put the link right underneath this video